[Music]
alright there's been all kinds of wild
speculation from the mainstream media
today about me and president Trump's
personal attorney Michael Kohn after my
name was mentioned in court proceedings
earlier today
now predictably without knowing all or
frankly any of the facts the media went
absolutely insane
wall-to-wall hour-by-hour coverage of
yours truly he stood up and he said the
name Sean Hannity how did he say it was
it like Sean Hannity Sean Hannity Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity Sean Hannity Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity Sean Hannity tun
Hannity Andy Kennedy Kennedy Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity's in the entity
Hannity Sean Hannity Sean Hannity Sean
Hannity John Hannity Hannity Hannity
Sean Hannity on Hannity on Hannity Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity Hannity Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity Don Hannity Sean
Hannity Sean Hannity Sean Hannity Sean
Hannity John Hannity all right am I
surprised by any of this no of course
not because this is what the media in
this country does let me set the record
straight here's the truth Michael Cole
never represented me in any legal matter
I never retained his services I never
received an invoice I never paid Michael
Cohen for legal fees I did have
occasional brief conversations with
Michael Kohn he's a great attorney about
legal questions I had or I was looking
for input and perspective my discussions
with Michael Kohn never rose to any
level that I needed to tell anyone that
I was asking him questions and to be
absolutely clear
they never involved any matter Andy
sorry to disappoint so many matter
between me or third party a third groups
at all and are my question is
exclusively almost focused on real
estate I said many times on my radio
show I hate the stock market I prefer
real estate Michael knows real estate so
in response to all the wild
want to set the record straight here
tonight I never asked Michael Kohn to
bring this proceeding on my behalf I
have no personal interest in this legal
matter that's all there is nothing more
so maybe the media could try and start
focusing in on the biggest abuse of
power scandal in this country or maybe
the Forgotten men and women in this
country who the 2016 election was about
you know jobs getting off of poverty out
of food stamps maybe we'll focus on that
national security a hundred and five out
of a hundred and five missiles hit their
targets